Your mission is to destroy every trace of
something known only as project starfish
starfish is a slang term for a butthole think
there's any connection we're all gonna die
Welcome back everyone this is my full suicide
squad breakdown video easter eggs for the entire
movie hopefully you've had a chance to see it
it's on hbo max right now and in theaters if you
haven't be sure to go see it if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's going to be a bunch of really
big stuff happening in the next week because
of marvel's what if episodes and a bunch more dc
stuff happening before the end of the year as well
careful for spoilers for the entire movie
and we'll just start at the beginning
so if you didn't know this movie is not meant
to be a reboot of the original suicide squad
movie as they explained with the timeline and the
characters that they bring back from the first one
it's meant to be kind of a sequel but not really a
sequel sort of a creative reimagining but the way
the timeline works that it picks up after the
events of the justice league movie because of
bloodsport's origin in putting superman in the icu
with a kryptonite bullet speaking of the devil too
originally james gunn said in the first version
of his story the suicide squad instead of going
up against starro we're going to be facing or
trying to track down an evil version of superman
who is being controlled by someone else sort of
reminding you of the nightmare scene from the
justice league snyder cut with evil superman being
controlled by the anti-life equation in dark side
a lot of people also wondering why didn't superman
or the other justice league members know about
what was going on with starro here in this nazi
base jodenheim i think the idea is that because
it had been down here since before superman landed
on planet earth so he wasn't looking for it then
once they did learn about superman's powers they
just reinforced some of the lab walls with lead so
that he wouldn't be able to detect what was going
on down there but the way they play it is as if
this is like the next mission in a long line of
missions that amanda waller has been sending task
force x the suicide squad out on year to year as
events have gone on since the events of the first
suicide squad movie but the actual movie opens
over the credits with johnny cash's folsom prison
blues as they introduce the first suicide squad
team the fake out team as we'll call them the
distraction that amanda waller creates that allows
the second team to actually enact their mission
amanda waller herself gets a big boss level
upgrade in terms of her level of shadiness during
this movie if you thought that she was underhanded
during the first film and kind of villainous
she's way worse during this film the whole idea
though is that every single character in this
movie is kind of a villain just to different
degrees some of them are worse than others
and arguably the real main villain isn't even
starro even though he's literally the biggest
villain in the film is actually secretly revealed
to be the us government in the military that's
behind everything that precipitates the events of
the film but they open with a slightly different
version of a roll call montage that will be got
during the first suicide squad movie introducing
the different team members from team a the first
team starting with michael rooker's savant who is
a batman villain his special abilities are similar
to bloodsport and peacemaker he's a sharpshooter
he's supposed to be a genius later amanda waller
also kind of sets up that joke with each team
member supposedly being carefully selected for
their unique abilities implying that they're
supposed to have different abilities but when
amanda waller says it's a blood sport and he calls
her out on it like wait a minute are you playing a
joke on me because peacemaker's the exact same as
me he has the same abilities it's her giving away
her ruse giving away the secret mission within a
mission that she's running that she's secretly
double crossing all them which is a big trope of
suicide squad stories in every suicide squad story
there are a couple things that have to happen
it has to be a group of really despicable
characters that try to do a little bit of good
they have to kill off a couple of the team
members at least in amanda waller always
has to double cross the team and when i said there
are a lot of record drop moments during the movie
a lot of those record drop moments are because of
different double crosses there are many different
double crosses that happen the big difference
though in the way they opened this new movie from
the original suicide squad movie is they get right
into the mission within moments of the opening
scene when they're implanting the bomb in his head
the doctor is played by john ostrander himself
the creator of the suicide squad in the comics
it's like his version of a stanley cameo scene
rick flagg comes back from the first film giving
you a sense for the timeline the continuity with
that first film like i said takes place after
the events of the justice league movie because
of bloodsport's history with superman also because
rick flagg captain boomerang harley quinn are back
and they referenced the events of that first
mission that they went on this is just meant
to feel like the next mission that they go on the
whole idea being that amanda waller just sends out
iterations of task force x all the time shotgun
style just throwing bodies at a problem because
she literally does not care whether any of them
live or die only that the mission gets completed
which sort of sets up the whole idea of the two
different teams then when they introduce the
rest of that first team rick flagg says that they
think the term suicide squad is derogatory their
true name is task force x that's actually a big
comic book easter egg when john ostrander first
created the suicide squad the original name of the
team was task force x we meet nathan fillion's tdk
and even though he refuses to explain it to the
other characters tdk stands for the detachable kid
because of his ability to detach his arms and the
way they play the visual effect of it is almost
like you're pulling the arms off an action figure
the way nathan philian described him is that he
was supposed to be annoying and pretty useless
in a fight which he was and if you thought it
was weird that some of these characters feel like
such big douchebags the whole idea is they did
that on purpose because they were killing them off
really quickly at the beginning of the film pete
davidson is probably the best example that like he
feels like this crazy douchebag character but he
is the first one to die they bring back captain
boomerang from that first film and then later
when harley boards the plane and says hello to
him like welcome back haven't seen you since the
last mission they're just referencing the events
of that first movie harley quinn saying that she
wound up back in bel reeve because she had road
rage inside a bank so this is also meant to be
after the events of the birds of prey movie at
some point after that she robbed another bank got
arrested and she is wearing an alternate version
of her costume from the comics that red costume
with the jacket it says live fast die clown on the
back which is a reference to the joker james gunn
did say though that he never really planned on
using joker in this movie but he is still alive in
present day in the dc universe so even though you
don't see him in this movie he's still presently
running around gotham committing crimes we meet
flulaborg's javelin it was so weird to see him
in this movie he started out as a comedy youtuber
i'm always surprised when i see former youtubers
show up in big movies like this he's only in
the movie to be this joke throwaway character
like pete davison's black guard and to set up that
whole twist with harley quinn killing starro with
the javelin but it was fun to see him pop up they
introduced mon gal from the superman mythology in
the comics also establishing the fact that aliens
being on earth is not a new thing superman is an
alien obviously so it was a big deal during the
man of steel movie when he came to earth and
everybody freaked out like oh my god aliens but
it also helps foreshadow the starro twist the idea
that starro came to earth even before superman's
pod so the government knew about the existence of
extraterrestrials long before superman ever showed
up but just didn't say anything because like they
established during the movie they're all super
shady then we meet weasel probably the biggest
wtf joke character of the whole movie because of
the way they bring him back in that post-credits
scene after killing him off in the first seven
minutes of the film just to give you an idea of
weasel's character james gunn said that mentally
he's supposed to be so dumb he's barely aware of
his surroundings like rick flagg said we think
that he agreed to come on the mission we're not
totally sure james gunn said that he's supposed to
make king shark seem like a genius in comparison
he's being played by sean gunn in motion capture
his brother who also has a separate cameo scene
when they're introducing bloodsport's character so
sean gunn is in the movie twice as two different
characters this character here that he's playing
as some of you probably guessed because he has all
the dates tattooed around his head is calendar
man from batman the long halloween is just like
the guardians of the galaxy movies he plays both
kraglin and he's the on-set stand-in double for
rocket raccoon so now he's played two different
fur cover creatures the reason why weasel looks so
hilariously freaky is because james gunn said he
was based on the look of bill the cat the cartoon
strip cat who was purposefully created to look
really horrible and gross in a funny way as the
team rolls out they establish the whole vibe of
amanda waller's support team inside the command
center all them laying bets on who's going to die
first who's going to survive steve agee is playing
john economos he's coming back for the peacemaker
series but he's also the on-set motion capture
double for king shark so just like sean gunn he
was in the movie twice as two different characters
they give you a brief look at all their criminal
records they joke about how weird the characters
are like one of them asks if mon gal is some sort
of alien is she a god that's also a bit of a setup
for king shark's character because he is the son
of the shark god they also want to establish the
idea that the team members here amanda waller's
team doesn't really care about these members
they haven't done a lot of research about them
they're not meant to be very important like who
cares about these people setting up the big joke
about them not knowing that weasel couldn't swim
when he drowns immediately after jumping out the
back of the plane harley quinn who has a thick
brooklyn accent claims american women love accents
because they don't got none a lot of the comedy
from her character in the movie a lot of the wtf
moments are built on the fact that she's a walking
contradiction and has zero impulse control i
enjoyed what james gunn did with her character in
this movie a little more than what they did with
her in the first movie in the birds of prey movie
margot robbie was just fantastic in general though
they hit the beach seemingly killing weasel in the
process hilariously and reveal amanda waller's
ruse when blackguard gives them away saying that
he contacted the courthouse maltese army
ahead of time to exchange his own safety
the whole idea though is that amanda waller set
this up herself she engineered this situation
purposefully allowing blackguard to think
that he was getting away with his double cross
setting their team to fail as a distraction so
the entire cultural maltese army would be busy
on this side of the island while the second team
with bloodsport was landing on the other side
of the island they shoot his face off immediately
and then kill the rest of the team almost the rest
of the team in rapid succession each death more
gruesome and funny than the last r.i.p savann who
just completely flips out gets killed by amanda
waller using the bomb in his head later the bird
lands on his head pecking at him eating him as if
it's karma coming back around for him killing the
bird at the beginning of the movie with his ball
r.i.p captain boomerang and mongal who get taken
out by the helicopter tdk is probably one of the
funniest death scenes just because of the way he
goes out with him shooting his arms and him
writhing on the beach in the distance javelin
winds up giving harley quinn his javelin to set
up the starro kill but she carries it around for
the entire movie not really sure what to do with
it she doesn't really use it for the first time
until she kills all the guards while she's
escaping that prison then after they get rid
of most of that first team they play the song
the people who have died by the jim carroll band
commenting on the action then they reveal team two
with idris elba's bloodsport he was meant to be
sort of a replacement for will smith's deadshot
during the movie but team two is basically
bloodsport king shark probably one of the best
characters in the movie polka dot man played by
david josh mallishien from the ant-man movies he
was also in a dc movie before this too he played
one of the joker's thugs during batman the dark
knight ratcatcher 2 then john cena's peacemaker
character who we also learn is obviously on
that whole secret mission within the mission
so bloodsport like i said thrown in bellrie
prison for shooting henry cavill's superman
with a kryptonite bullet after the events of the
justice league movie he's a mercenary for hire so
odds are pretty good that it was lex luthor that
hired him to shoot superman i also think giving
bloodsport this history with superman would have
tied in with that original storyline james gunn
was going to do where the suicide squad would have
gone after superman instead of going after starro
as they introduced the rest of that team
bloodsport crosses paths with some of the members
of team one may they rest in peace they make that
funny joke about peacemaker being the exact same
as bloodsport having the exact same abilities like
what like amanda waller literally uses the same
sentence to introduce him his father trained
him to kill him from the moment he was born
in his hands anything is a deadly weapon the exact
same sentence she used to explain bloodsport's
character earlier like i said this whole twist is
meant to set up her eventual ruse in the double
cross that happens later they introduced king
shark probably one of my favorite characters
during the film he's voiced by sylvester stallone
if you couldn't tell sylvester stallone also
another one of those marvel actors from the
guardians of the galaxy movies they set up king
shark's backstory briefly saying that he is the
son of a shark god and a human woman they do try
to use his actual birth name in the movie a couple
times his real name is nanaue the upside-down book
that he's reading when they introduce him is just
varieties of religious experience which is a book
written by harvard professor this is psychological
study of individual private religious experiences
and mysticism so it's just meant to show you
that he is trying his best to be a good boy
he just wants to make friends he is trying to be
deeper as a character here like there's more going
on inside him they introduce ratcatcher 2 she's
the daughter of the original rat catcher character
from the dc comics played by taika watiti
also from the thor movies another marvel actor
director her main rat friend sebastian was
actually a combination of special effects
in a real rat that they used on set in the funny
coincidence here because we just met king shark is
that the rat that they used in the movie was named
jaws in real life polka dot man was probably one
of the mvps of the movie he got to stick it to
his mother one last time and become a superhero
they explained that his mother was a former star
lab scientist who experimented on her children
infecting them with an alien virus from another
dimension hoping that it would give them powers
and it did just not the fun kind of powers his
body generates those polka dots that explode and
he has to discharge them a couple times a day
or they'll consume his body from the inside out
the whole scene of king shark getting so hungry
that he tries to eat rat catcher 2 is just to
bring them closer together as friends set up his
arc his desire to actually have a friend as he
says he hasn't got any they also established
bloodsport's irrational fear of rats here too
but they explained that it was because of the way
his father tortured him as a child sticking him
in the box of starving rats for a full day and
setting up the payoff for the end of the movie
where he's finally able to pet sebastian who falls
asleep on its leg bloodsport and peacemaker have
their wtf kill count contest when they think that
they're saving rick flagg from the rebels setting
up the end of the movie with their big gunslinger
standoff moment each one of them trying to outdo
the other with more creative kills like bloodsport
criticizes him for using bullets that are too big
in peacemaker laughs in his face but setting
up the big twist was able to defeat peacemaker
using the smaller round they introduced that new
courtois maltese dictator in his general while
explaining starro's backstory and how he came to
earth and peter capaldi's thinker he's playing
a version of the thinker from the new 52 suicide
squad comics that they never really gave a name to
so in this movie james gunn just calls him gaius
graves they explained that starro wound up being
taken in by american astronauts in the 1990s when
he drifted into earth's orbit near their shuttle
and after he mind controlled them and brought
their shuttle back to the u.s the government
captured him took him to corto matis where they
could experiment on him on this old nazi base that
they had taken over and weaponize his mind control
abilities that's also when the american government
set up the previous dictator by making the bargain
with him to get rid of the old nazis get them
out of yodenheim so that the american government
could move in with starro so that's really why the
american government is kind of the true villain
of the film they haul in harley quinn because
this dictator wants a political marriage with her
to legitimize himself in the eyes of the locals
of courthold maltese because they view her at
least on the island as a rebel hero because they
themselves are kind of rebels when she turns on a
dime and kills him explaining the promise she made
to herself to kill any man she got close to if she
sends a red flag that's a reference to her history
with the joker most of the tattoos that you see on
here too are tattoos from the events of the first
film like she's had these tattoos for a long time
back with the surviving team members they set up
their plan to capture the thinker and set up the
twist with polka dot man's mother where's your
mother now oh she's everywhere because he cannot
stop hallucinating her and i do love the joke
about king shark trying to disguise himself with
the fake mustache but nope shark wearing pants and
a fake mustache just aren't going to cut it it's
very similar to the joke with drax being invisible
during infinity war when amanda waller says that
she's playing golf with senator cray this weekend
joseph cray is a shady u.s senator in the comics
implied to be selling government information
he was also a character they used during arrow
season one he was one of the people on oliver's
list so just reinforcing the idea that amanda
baller has a lot of dealings with very shady
governmental figures when they actually go to the
bar and start drinking and bonding even sebastian
the rat getting a drink there's another marvel
guardians of the galaxy cameo scene from palm
clementia who plays mantis in those movies she's
one of the dancers performing on stage peacemaker
calls bloodsport inspector gadget just because
of the way his weapons work rick flagg says that
it could be their last drink together and it is
foreshadowing his eventual death because he gets
killed off by peacemaker shortly after this then
bloodsport uses the exact same trick amanda waller
used at the beginning of the movie splitting the
team in half using half of them as a distraction
getting captured on purpose allowing the other
half to escape with the thinker then they use
those creative transitions for more commentary
jokes operation yodenheim no wait operation harley
because we have to go save harlequin first which
they pay off by having harley quinn save herself
and the cool thing here is that margot robbie
actually performed all these stunts when she was
stealing the keys unlocking the lock on her own
like she really used her foot to yoink that key
and then pull it over her head and unlock it with
her toes james gunn said the whole montage of her
killing all the guards with the flowers in the
javelin was always planned to be this way it's
meant to be her perception of what's happening as
it unfolds like we're seeing what harley quinn is
imagining around her while she's killing these
guards i also love the way they intercut this
with the montage of rick flagg's team preparing
to break in and save her time perfectly so that
just as they roll into action she's walking
up with the javelin like hey guys what's up
when they're charging the front door and king
shark seems like he hulks out just ripping the
guard in half the reason why he seems like he
gets way more powerful is because he actually
does get more powerful when he's in water then as
half the group sets all the charges to blow up the
base thinker takes rick flagg and ratcatcher to
his starro lab in the basement levels and reveals
the full scope of the us government's dirty little
secrets highlighted by the other funny creative
transition with the elevator button thinker
explains the american government's been sponsoring
his research this whole time for the past 30 years
trying to weaponize starro when he says he named
him starro the conqueror and it's meant to be a
derisive name that's a reference to his original
comic book name when he first debuted in the
justice league comics he was the justice league's
very first team-up villain later at the end of the
movie when they flashed that suicide squad versus
starro the conqueror title that's also a reference
to that original justice league comic book
starro begs rick flagg to help him escape saying
thinker's been torturing him for the past 30 years
and he's not lying you're supposed to feel bad
for starro even though he does wind up killing a
ton of people in a little while rick flagg vows
to release the evidence of the us government's
deceptions to the rest of the world peacemaker
then pulls his double cross revealing amanda
waller's secret deception they have their
knock-down drag out fight to the death and
even though you can see peacemaker feels really
bad about it he does kill rick flagg so r.i.p
while this is happening though the bombs have
already gone off and the buildings collapsing
around them so they flash back in time then to
show you what was happening with the other half
of the team before the bombs went off you see king
shark and another floor of the building trying
to make some new friends or so he thinks until
those really messed up looking alien jellyfish
start eating him if it wasn't clear those
were also meant to be aliens just like starro
that the thinker and the nazis before him were
experimenting on they said at the whole milton
joke with harley quinn not remembering the rebel
that was named milton who was driving the car for
them this whole time later confusing bloodsport
for milton nope not my name that's not who i am
polka dot man accidentally sets off the
explosives blowing the building in half
and that's when their timeline catches up with
the events of the peacemaker versus rick flagg
and ratcatcher scenes so that just as bloodsport
has his wtf funny scene falling through all the
different floors he lands smack dab in front of
them just in time to see what peacemaker is doing
he just sees the double cross and immediately
understands what's going on and they have their
big gunslinger standoff moment finally paying off
the reference about which type of bullet was best
earlier in the movie when they were arguing
about who was the better crack shot and then
later peacemaker bragging about his larger rounds
bloodsport beats him by using a much smaller round
to pierce his bullet then gets him in the throat
causing him to bleed so fast that he passes out
setting up the events of the post-credits
scene then he takes the hard drive of evidence
also setting up his bargain with amanda waller
at the end of the movie steve agees john economos
character makes a kaiju reference and amanda
waller orders the team to bail on the island
and even though they're kind of vegas to why she
says it's not their problem anymore the whole idea
is that the base was destroyed and that was the
mission destroy the data she never really cared
about destroying the actual starro monster it
implies that any damage the starro is going
to cause now on the island they'll just blame on
the local dictator and let somebody else clean up
like it's not america's problem anymore and just
to reinforce the idea of how despicable she is
during this movie when they try to stay to help
the locals she legit tries to detonate all the
bombs in their heads and is only stopped when the
support staff rebels knocking her out before she
can they pay off the joke about polka dot man's
mother when he supercharges his attack disabling
starro he gets to be a superhero for one single
hot minute before he goes out r.i.p they pay off
rat catcher 2's ability with the army of rats and
harley quinn's javelin joke from the beginning of
the movie like oh now i know what this was for
this whole time in r.i.p starro they imply that
he's dead at the end of the movie but because of
the way he spawns there could always be another
version of starro that spawned and survives
into future dc movies bloodsport uploads that
evidence to a private cloud server and agrees not
to release it so long as amanda waller lets them
all go free and doesn't retaliate and finally
accepts the friendship of sebastian the rat
then the first post credit scene is just meant
to be a funny moment paying off the weasel joke
from the beginning of the movie when they killed
him off or seemingly killed him off kind of makes
some noises and looks around like what happened to
everybody where'd everybody go and then just lopes
off into the jungle all funny like off to eat
more children i guess he'll be like the courtois
maltese version of el chupacabra from now on
then the second post-credits scene actually sets
up the john cena peacemaker hbo series so after
another short time jump john economos and emilia
harcourt's character show up at his hospital
room the doctor says he'll be fine soon but
like what's the big deal why do you need him and
emilia says they need him to help save the world
and the peacemaker episodes will just be him going
on more missions for amanda waller and they also
said that the peacemaker series would cross over
with other future dc movies but they didn't say
which movies those will be james gunn wrote all
the peacemaker episodes himself he also directed
five of the eight episodes they're eight episodes
total they'll start in january and i will be doing
full videos for all those if you spotted any
big easter eggs or references that i didn't
talk about during the video just write them
below in the comments next week marvel's what
if is starting my marvel what if episode will
post on wednesday it'll be the exact same video
schedule as my loki episodes that i did everyone
click here for my full suicide squad movie post
credit scene video and click here for my brand new
marvel what if episode 1 trailer in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!